hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
now we're looking at the positive
content of her ethics she's putting
forth the kind of ideal rational egoist
should behave in certain ways and should
not behave in other grades and there's
may be a requirement of consistency one
of the things that this is connected
with that we're not going to get into
detail is what she calls these virtues
and she doesn't mean by them exactly
what virtue ethicist mean by virtues she
calls these acts she doesn't call them
you know habits she sees them as some
someone like commitments but there are
things like rationality and integrity
justice and so think of these as sort of
good character traits it's not just
about what you do in the particular
instance it's about what you do over
time the kind of character the kind of
person that you develop yourself into
interestingly she talks about like one
of these virtues actually being she's
got the word moral ambitiousness you
know being being being sort of eager to
make something of yourself to make
yourself into a better person now what
what counts as being a better person for
real well if you boil it down if you
want to get down with the really
simplest is you could say there's three
different sets of responses and you can
see this in the two chapters that I've
given here from this the one about the
Objectivist ethics among the lifeboat
ethics stop she says that there's three
responses
to those who have to damage them what
sort of response should that provoke so
to people who actually have you know
character traits who act in this this
way the commitments to being just having
integrity to you know being productive
to not you know relying on other people
for their their livelihood for thinking
things through on their own for making
reason the sole criteria by which they
do things that's what she calls
rationality what were the appropriate
response needs to value them yeah it's
interesting
she says you value those kinds of people
not from an altruistic kind of way were
you saying that person is good in and of
themselves and therefore I must like
take care of them or love them or treat
them well or invite them over to the
house on Saturday night or pickle you
know whatever concrete thing you want
give them a call every salon okay you
know write a letter of recommendation
for them she sees that as being such as
being properly selfish if I recognize
integrity in you and I want to hang out
with you because of that I'm enjoying
his integrity I'm getting something out
of it if he doesn't have that I wouldn't
want him to hang out this is how ran
season four it's everybody house just
say one marry people who are not
particularly well developed she says
that we always certain amount of respect
[Music]
but what their respect means is that
that person does not matter particularly
for me I might help them out if they
need it but I'm not required to go seek
out opportunities for helping them as a
matter of fact letting them may actually
figure out things for themself is what
might make them eventually virtuous
which then might lead me to love or
become friends with or esteem them all I
really ought to do is not mess with them
and if I feel like helping them out that
I can do so if I see a drowning child
you know floating by the river of course
I'm not gonna say well I don't know
about the virtues of this child so I
think I'll just you know respect them
let them float on by she doesn't say
that but she says well you should
evaluate the situation based on what
you're actually going to get out of and
what the goods are the the defenseless
child probably you have a greater
obligation to them in that situation not
not all the time but in that situation
then somebody who's an Olympic swimmer
is clocked in half you know a little bit
days grown adults with the inner tube
who's saying help help
you know the defenseless child is a
little bit different but even then it's
going to be based on your own you know
sense of values and what you're getting
out of it
if you're putting your life than this
she says it should be for you good
reasons what respect might actually not
extend that far in a lot of cases then
for people who are aggressive or people
who are frauds or parasites what do you
owe them not only do you owe them
nothing but you're entitled to use
forcing them to defend yourself to
defend your interests to defend yourself
as a rational being as a
the values now she's got some really
interesting discussions in there about
how issues that can people that that we
do and and why we value the way we do
she says the proper manner of judging
with Leonard whether when or rather one
should help another person is by
reference to one's own rational
self-interest and one's own hierarchy of
values you know if I have to choose
between helping my friend who's a
philosophy colleague and helping
somebody who is in the music industry
I'm probably not my philosophy colleague
because I read philosophy a little
higher than music like music a lot but
there's a lot of a lot more people doing
you know great stuff of music that don't
need that much help and that has made
people in philosophy if you ask me you
know to choose between helping my own
kid and helping ten other kids Rand
would say you help your own kit because
you you actually value your own kid your
kid focuses higher in your hierarchy of
values
she says the time money or effort one
gives to the risk long take should be
proportionate to the value of the person
in relation to one's own happiness my
kids matter to my happiness my wife
matters to my happiness somebody else's
wife not quite so much almost maybe
they're my friend or you know my
friend's wife and I care about how he's
effective so I better help his wife with
X Y Z things same thing could have apply
to students you know by actually buy by
brands logic I should be treating two of
them two of the students have taken
classes of made previously better than
all the rest of the class because I've
already formed a connection
that I'm just sort of forming over the
course of time reading your papers and
making things with them
so maybe actually that can lead to some
unfairness Rand would say no problem
with that actually how does this drink
the rest of it
sound fair unfair sounds unfair to me
actually this will have a problem but
then you know if I actually value
fairness that's in my hierarchy of
values right I think the fairness
matters that's something that I can
choose to make matter the conscience you
brought that up earlier if I want to
listen to conscience as a guide I'm the
one who's choosing to put it up here if
I say I can't do this for this person
over here because that would violate my
conscience I'm saying conscience retired
and pleasing this person who I might get
something from now if she goes out and
she talks about she's loving friendship
are profoundly personal selfish values
love is an expression and assertion of
self esteem a response to one's own
values in the person of the other we
love what we find in the other person
because we value that yeah there for
rands ethics this would be something
where it really differs from a lot of
religious ethics there is no obligation
to love people to esteem them it's
something that you choose to do on the
basis of seeing something in them so the
whole notion of like loving somebody
despite their flaws very alien terrain
unless you're getting something out of
that person she says what should you
grains of strangers goodwill respect and
she goes she's got this very nice
discussion about
how do you know if somebody's actually
living up to their their values with
respect to this is where integrity comes
in as a virtue
she says if a man is able to swim and
say this drowning wife it becomes panic
he gets into an unjustified irrational
fear lets her drown then spends his life
in loneliness and misery a lot of
applause for saying well how would you
treat something like that would you want
to be the response to that they could
have saved her he could say here but he
froze up and she dropped what says your
friend or your yeah yeah would you I
mean you feel less sympathy than if like
he had exerted everything in Hamill's
died himself what do you think the rest
you agree without her yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah I feel bad but in the sense
that I kind of like lose a little bit
respect like feel bad because we like
yeah then this is what Ramsay actually
that's interesting
Hurley thing ended his life yeah well
that's now that's gonna be exactly the
sort of things she's saying she says you
would condemn him morally for his
treason to himself in his own values
that is failure to fight for the
preservation of a value crucial to his
own happiness his wife is necessary for
his happiness and yet he doesn't go all
the way to fight for that and he says
she says since one on one's own
happiness is the moral purpose of life
the man who fails to achieve it because
of his own default it's morally guilty
she says this is a lack of integrity the
virtue involved in helping those 1/1
lobs is integrity loyalty to one's own
convictions and values it's the policy
of sticking to what your values actually
are I think there is a sort of moral
ambivalence here the feeling is you know
it is too bad that that happened but you
know why did you let this happen those
would both come into play because
there's a contradict
his action doesn't there if I claim that
let's say I'm the guy and I say my wife
is absolutely necessary for my happiness
I can't possibly imagine life without
her I'd better safer because otherwise
I'm not really living up to what I say
that's that's integrity and that's sort
of at the core of what man is talking
about she has one virtue that she thinks
is most primary that's rationality but
integrity also seems to be particularly
important when it comes to personal
relationships so the other thing that
she talks about is this notion of the
traitor not trait or like you know
betraying something but trade your trade
trading things back and forth her ideal
is the person who neither yes nor takes
what is undeserved or on earth so
everything that I want to expect from
you I want to earn in one way or another
everything that I give to you want to be
and what you actually deserve and if the
relationship is set up like that then
everything is completely fair and
rational this is where justice would
come in verge of justice so somebody
who's not productive really can't claim
to expect much from others rather than
say if you don't you know if you don't
work you you shouldn't eat another pie
right is is sort of the basis of this
but if we want to be looked at as good
people if we want to be valued by other
people we have to actually give them
some reason to value of us we have to
pretty grim develop these good character
traits that make us worthy of something
more than just mere
will it respect friendship love
admiration all those sorts of things
that's what the trader can do and I
freed who brought up the the problem of
a competition yeah
one of the problems with egoism but a
lot of people bring up is that it's
going to inevitably gonna bring us into
competition that will have conflict with
each other
according to rain if everybody acts as a
rational Ulis then we're not going to
conflict we'll be able to work out you
know you and I want the same thing we'll
sit down and we'll actually talk it out
and figure out how we can share in it
you get it on Saturdays and I can about
Sunday's on Wednesdays and so on down
the line
it's only when rationality fails that
conflict becomes inevitable for somebody
like Graham